I think that one of the great mistakes
that women make
is they don't think about the
consequences of their choices and
they've been used their entire life of
being forgiven for making choices that
have
consequences and when guys like me come
around and say things like this they're
like well that's not the same you can't
possibly say or think
that because it's simply
not it's not the same but it's the same
level of
[__] it's the same concept of this
person has a standard you for money
versus someone contributing or trying to
no no not even the same at all it's
money materialistic [__] that's here on
Earth I completely understand what
you're saying lost her husband [__]
I completely understand what you're
saying but to a guy like me when I see
it for what it is it's the same level of
[__] you just said what it is why is
it why is it why is it that women can
hold men to to certain standards but men
can't hold women to certain standards
like why are you able to disqualify a
guy because he asks you to pay for his
kid in a daycare center but I can't
disqualify a woman because she's
tattooed of momento of another man on
her
body you see what I'm saying right thing
he asked me to pay for yes maybe I
consider it right but I mean you can
have standards but men can't have
standards his the mother of his child is
still alive that wasn't my like Gamble
to that it's not my [__] to deal with my
best friend who lost her husband
different that's got it but I mean
you're talking about standards got it
but I mean you're talking about
standards and dating right it's the
exact same thing yeah I was manipulated
I I'm admitting that that's why I'm on
my this show right now like yeah I got
[__] over and he used me financially
and I [__] got out of it but what I'm
saying is you comparing that to a woman
who lost her husband and father of her
[__] kids no
that's not the that's not the argument
that's aru for your kids dayare I think
you're missing the
point you have a certain standard you
have a line in the sand that's a bottom
line and your Line in the Sand was I'm
not going to deal with a guy that's
going to be asking me to be paying for
his kids daycare yeah but you twisted
that around like I that's your standard
that's your line in the stand like
you're allowed to have that standard and
disqualify a guy but you're saying that
a man can't have a standard and
disqualify a woman because she's
tattooed a momento of another man on her
body yeah but the way how does that make
sense why do you get standards but I
don't I didn't say you don't get
standards but the way you compareed
those two neck and neck when those were
conversations that were had over 30
minutes ago they're not even like
compromisable this is up they are in the
sense in the regard that they're
disqualifying
standards
what I'm I'm just like I'm really
confused like you're asking for a
woman's
perspective this is a widow she lost her
husband and you're comparing to some
douchebag I met online this is a child
in a daycare center that needs care
Caitlyn and you're refusing to pay for
it because they H the child has a mother
okay and why would I want to invite a
woman into my life that holds a place in
her heart and has marked her body with
that
man I don't care how he died it doesn't
matter to me it's not my
problem you see what I'm saying though
right like you're allowed to set a
standard in your dating world but a man
is not allowed to set a standard in his
world how is that fair I met a man and
he had a tattoo of his his wife that
passed and he also had children with I
personally would admire that I would
respect that and that's what trying to
say this is your personal standard and
we have our women are very very
different like men will routinely pay
for another man's kids right like if the
tables were returned and it was a guy
dealing with you and you needed him to
pay for your kids in daycare there's
lots of guys out there that that will do
something like that yeah because men and
women are totally different I have more
self resect than that I like I don't I'm
not asking for charity like and then
when I saw that I was taking no I know
but I mean like the point that you're
missing Caitlyn is that we can all hold
people to standards that we want to hold
them to you can't tell me what my
standards are and I can't tell you what
your standards are I can't tell you
Caitlyn that was shallow of you not to
pay for that man's child in
daycare that's your standard that's your
Line in the Sand you drew that line he
crossed it he's out now right so a line
in the sand for a guy like me and when I
talk to guys like if I had a guy you
know book me for a consult and he's like
hey Rich this is what I do for a living
blah blah blah and I'm dealing with this
woman but this bothers me right I would
say yeah it bothers you for a reason
what's what does God like say here
tattoos are forbiding and against the
Bible it's a big red flag regardless of
your excuse show your care another way
it doesn't matter what you say so
there's just one person in the live chat
that's saying that right I mean that's
fine everyone has it like we're human we
have opinion I'm just saying like what I
thought that she went through vers like
paying for someone's day I get it but
you're her friend and you're a woman and
you have your own you know way of
dealing with things and you're emotional
about it and stuff like that but I don't
expect you to see it from the
perspective of a man I'm just telling
you what the perspective is it is a line
in the sand that I that I would draw had
I met a woman that had a Mark or marks
on her body representative of another
man that means that she's holding a
place in her heart for that guy and I
can't take a woman that does that
seriously there's other guys out there
that'll do it there's lots of guys out
there that'll do it not of my caliber
even if it's like 10 years later you'll
never take a woman seriously if she has
like a momentum of any man it's
permanent no it's permanent well no sure
but like time like okay okay I'm just
asking I'm just asking I'm I'm learning
too I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the fulllength
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out